underneath I can't do basic math I'm  gonna be a little disappointed in myself  I feel very confident I did really well  in math back in high school so she'll be  pretty good  [Music]  19 times 18  no man got it haha oh yeah just call on  him I think he's got it  [Music]  [Music]  125 I got it is it I can do it I just  need a little time you know I mean he's  quick 20 that was 1964 stabs 125 I  [Music]  thought was gonna lose for a minute  there I think I did by adults proud and  expected 36  [Music]  620 for 225 I feel a little bit ashamed  but I'm part of the kids they're the  future of this country 7 times 9 63 9  times 1/6 it - I still feel good because  they're grown-ups and I'm just kidding  well I'm very glad I'd be everyone  because I gave it my very best I think  it's just he's got these quick arms that  go up really fast I think that's it's  really not the math it's more like his  quick arm  [Music]